after decades of criticism and
resistance change maybe coming to one of
the National Football League's oldest
franchises the Washington Redskins under
pressure from sponsors and advocacy
groups said Friday they are reviewing
their name considered by many to be
racially insensitive despite carrying
the same moniker for nearly 90 years
washington dc's pro football team could
be changing in a statement the team said
in light of recent events around our
country and feedback from our community
the Washington Redskins are announcing
the team will undergo a thorough review
of the team's name the move comes after
dozens of investors reportedly sent
letters to FedEx PepsiCo and Nike
threatened to terminate their
relationships with the team unless it
changed its name and now team owner
Daniel Snyder appears to be backtracking
on past vows to never make that change
it was amazing that we've reached this
point
Andrew Brandt is the director of
Villanova's Mourad Center for sports law
and a former NFL executive he says other
NFL owners may be nudging Snyder we're
in a different climate we're in a
different atmosphere and these owners
that had never pressured and that may be
too strong a word mr. Snyder to change
the name of his team maybe taking a
different tact right now NFL
Commissioner Roger Goodell said in the
last few weeks we have had ongoing
discussions with Dan and we're
supportive of this important step
pressure to make a name change may not
be limited to the NFL late last night
the Cleveland Indians released a
statement saying they are determining
the way forward with their team name
Brandt says well support among NFL
officials is there to change
Washington's name a wider review of
mascots is causing some to be concerned
here's the refrain I get where does it
end we may be getting into his slippery
slope